conseil otan russie se réunit donc à
nouveau pour tenter d'avancer sur le
dossier ukrainien les états unis et
leurs alliés européens vont engager ce
mercredi des discussions avec moscou
cette fois au siège de l'alliance
l'objectif désamorcer un lot risque d'un
nouveau conflit en ukraine c'est
l'occasion pour vous allez là et dit
bonjour ali notre spécialiste économique
d'évaluer les moyens de pression sur sur
la russie on en a déjà parlé ces
dernières semaines pas question de
recourir à la guerre alors que
reste-t-il comme levier pour empêcher
les soldats russes dans meyer l'ukraine
on imagine les sanctions en tout cas la
menace de sanctions bah on n'a pas le
choix c'est sans doute la plus grave
crise post guerre froide qui lie à entre
les deux anciens camps qui ont mené la
guerre de
l'économie internationale et la
politique internationale de 45 à 1989
donc il n'est pas question en effet pour
l'ouest d'aller mourir pour kiev donc la
perspective de la guerre elle n'est pas
là il va falloir s'entendre clairement
avec la russie le seul recours des
occidentaux ce sont les sanctions il en
existe déjà depuis 2014 la russie est
sous sanction avec un s puisque il ya
plusieurs éléments plusieurs événements
qui ont donné lieu à des sanctions de la
part des états unis de la part de
l'union européenne 2014 c'est évidemment
la question du don base c'est de la
question de la crimée et c'est donc
c'est essentiellement deux types de
sanctions qui visent d'abord et avant
tout des personnalités plus de 700
permal personnalités russes ou proches
de la russie ont été sanctionnés depuis
2000 14 interdiction évidemment de
voyages et gel des avoirs lorsqu'ils ont
des avoirs de l'autre côté et puis
deuxième axe les entreprises donc on
sanctionne les entreprises
essentiellement visé les banques russes
le complexe évidemment militaires russes
et puis tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'énergie
interdiction d'investir en europe ou aux
états unis pour elle pas d'accès au
crédit pour ces entreprises est
évidemment limitation des exportations
les etats unis l'union européenne mais
également le japon applique une partie
de ses sanctions essentiellement sur les
personnalités avec l'interdiction de
voyager de visa et puis évidemment
l'ukraine applique ses sanctions contre
la russie lente qu'en essentiellement
sur les personnalités si on fait
rapidement calcul ça fait donc septembre
sanction c'est pas rien ça marche alors
du tout non clairement politiquement ça
ne marche pas puisque la russie ne pas
reculer et économiquement c'est assez
faible alors il ya on n'arrive pas à
savoir vraiment l'impact quelques études
qui disent que en gros ça coûterait
environ entre 1 5 et 2 points de pib à
la russie par an soit depuis 2014 100
milliards de dollars ça coûte aussi aux
occidentaux parce que du coup ils ne
font pas de business avec la russie peas
a un effet pervers quand même 7 sur
certains secteurs la russie obtient une
autonomie stratégique et autrement dit
sur l'agriculture par exemple eh bien
ils sont quasiment autonome allard qui
ne l'était pas avant la crise de 2014
alors du coup la grande question c'est
est-ce que ces sanctions pourraient
aller
plus loin c'est difficile quoi qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va couper le gaz entre
la russie et l'europe et les secondes et
menaçant avec ses gazoducs et 40% du gaz
arrive de sibérie donc je ne sais pas
envisagé on va sans doute
renforcer le contrôle sur les
exportations vers la russie notamment
pour les semi-conducteurs les
technologies de l'aviation etc et puis
les états unis nous parle d'une arme
nucléaire économique ce serait tout
simplement
d'exclure le réseau bancaire russe de
l'ensemble du réseau international à
travers la fameuse système qui est le
système swift qui est un système de
paiement entre banques donc exclure
totalement la russie là ce serait
vraiment une arme nucléaire économique
très forte contre la russie bon on l'a
fait concurrence à part vraiment marché
la russie c'est un autre pays c'est une
autre dimension on voit la menace est là
reste à voir comment ils vont s'entendre
à genève est aujourd'hui à l'otan ne
manquera pas de vous tenir informés
évidemment merci beaucoup elle est là et
10 pour le décryptage